نووي كلمه خفيفه على اللسان لكنها ثقيله
في ميزان الحرب بل مستقبلي كوكب الارض
بين الحين والاخر يخرج الرئيس الروسي
ليتحدث عن الاسلحه النوويه موجها للكلام
الى خصومه الغربيين في كل مره يرفع بوتين
التحدي عاليا فضغطه زر واحده كافيه لمحو
بلد باكمله بل اكثر
خبراء يرون ان تلويح الزعيم الروسي
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه ما هو الا هروب
من المشاكل الداخليه التي يتخبط فيها جراء
الازمه الناتجه عن العقوبات الاقتصاديه
الدوليه على بلاده بعد اطلاق العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
فسيد الكرملين يلجا الى سياسه حافه
الهاويه لاجبار خصومه على الجلوس لطاوله
المفاوضات يقول مراقبون الزعيم الروسي هدد
في غير ما مره باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
اذا اراد الغرب القضاء على روسيا وفق
تعبيره فلعالم بلا روسيا حسب عقيده موسكو
بوتين سبق ان هدد باحتمال نشوب حرب نوويه
خلال العام الماضي خاصه كلما تعثرت عمليته
العسكريه في اوكرانيا فالقوه الروسيه تقصف
المدن الاوكرانيه من الجو لكن الحرب
البريه لا تحقق الكثير من التقدم حديث
زعيم الكريم الجديد القديم عن الاسلحه
النوويه ياتي ايضا بعد اصدار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال بحقه فهل
سيفعلها بوتين ويلجا لاستخدام اسلحه لا
تبقي ولا تذر ام ان كلامه مجرد تهديدات
فقط لا ترقى الى مرحله الفعل بلال
الوجداني العربيه